welcome to shaq's edition of snotty nose
wings
i feel like snotty pippin up here hey
what's going on everybody for first week
feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and by popular demand we're joined today
by shaquille o'neal
he's one of the most dominant players in
nba history you can catch him as an
analyst on tnt's emmy award winning
inside the nba
and if all that weren't enough he's also
a globally recognized dj sensation
bringing shaq's funhouse to miami music
fest on march 29th
shaquille o'neal welcome to the show i'm
a big fan of your show and i know your
stuff is hot i don't trust you so i
brought my own milk
you brought your own jug you ever
brought my own milk you know just like
everyone else i saw your one chip
challenge so i have an idea but i do
have to ask how are you with spicy food
i don't eat spicy food however i got
embarrassed
about because i promised i wouldn't make
a face on eating those wings
i'm guaranteed on this show i will not
make a face
[Music]
just take a little bite like that
i really take a bite
[Music]
so you're one of the most accomplished
players in nba history you could
probably do a whole
episode around your hall of fame career
do you remember the first time you ever
smashed a backboard into a thousand
pieces
in high school in san antonio texas
but it was a cheap dunk uh i couldn't
dunk till my senior year so my junior
year we used to jump off
what they call apple boxes yeah we have
some on screen
i used to put an apple box and imagine
that i was in the nba
so one day i ran and took off and i hung
on the rim
and it broke and the glass shattered and
we ran out
the next day the gym teacher came right
to me and said i know you broke the
backboard
and he says you know what if you break a
real backboard next year when you're
starting on varsity
i won't be upset so every time i got in
the game i've seen you i would try to
dunk and dunk and then one game
in my senior year i broke it i took that
one down and i ran to the gym coach and
he gave me out
finally you did an amazing sit-down
interview with kobe bryant last year
where you two reconciled some of your
differences what was the most
we never had we never had any
differences you know people need to
understand that
in any relationship there's going to be
some turmoil
but when you don't have respect then
comes differences we always have respect
we just had a
a difference of opinion problems would
be us winning no championships at all
not three out of four i mean like i
always tell people like even though we
had our differences it's not like i'm
gonna see him at a restaurant eating
and then be like give me this chicken
wing give me the second chicken with
your little kobe
you know and biting through it
it's always about respect so working it
working it
what girl
[Music]
this one's a little harder but i'm not
going to make a face
are we allowed to drink water i can't if
you want actually i'm not because water
is going to activate it
you're trying to trick me but that's
what happened on tnt when i bit into
that ghost pepper chip
i was fine but it got caught by that it
was the water spot and then yeah
yeah so the water activated so i'm not
gonna let nothing activate it today
so there's a lot of debate about which
nba players can actually rap from
iman jumper to allen iverson to damien
lillard and i'm curious
is the only player to actually land a
recording deal with a major label
which nba players would you allow in
your cipher i mean i probably wouldn't
allow all of them
i never wanted an album deal arsenio
hall asked me to come on the show
and i was introducing the world to
shaquille o'neal i was like you know i
don't want to come on your show and just
be in a suit
flashing money and talking about what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna be different i
said so i'll do your interview but
afterwards you gotta let me rap with my
favorite rap group so for me it was just
a dream to wrap up my favorite rap group
so i did it here's the clip right here
check it out
so after that uh the next day people uh
called me and said hey we want to want
to give you a three album deal
10 million dollars i'm never going to
turn that down y'all get me all my
favorite people that i want to rap with
be part of completing my dreams and
it'll work
also i realize when you go platinum i
made
one or two million that's not enough
money for me
so i was like you know this is fun but i
don't i don't want to be a rapper i just
want to have fun doing it
just like djing i don't want to be the
greatest dj in the world i want to go
out and get that
that feeling of a game seven when you
see all those people that paid all that
money to watch you perform
i got to give them a show give me the
ball i see some kids out there jumping
they want me to score
that's what it's all about for me just
you know all about just basically having
fun
and then in addition to your own
platinum records you've been name
checked by some of the biggest rappers
ever from
biggie to lil wayne to 50 cent do you
have a favorite shaq lyric i'm slamming
like shaquille my you know i can say it
but you can't say it
oh
[Music]
which one is this right there
pepper garlic grapefruit onions and
carrots
still no face so you've established
yourself as something of a financial
guru for a lot of younger players
but is it true that you blew a million
dollars within 45 minutes of signing
with the magic in 92
yeah that's true what'd you buy i bought
a black 600 sec mercedes
because because one thing i forgot about
is fica you know who fike is
we didn't know about the taxes yeah i
don't know i didn't even know who fico
was so
and then i had no negotiating skill like
i probably could have got the car down
to 120.
but the guy's like yeah one one 138 in
each route
equal up to 150 i'll take it black one
with the wheels
i had to pull out i had to pull out
alpine deck you remember that the ones
you pull out with the leather
case so i pull up to my dad's house and
he said where's mine at so i'm like in
my mind a million
minus 150 i got 850 left i'm still rich
so i'll go buy him one
my mom almost i gotta hurt a little one
which is about a hundred
so i was left with about 600 so then
after
you know we're showing off our calls
i'll be back go to the mall
nice little rolex bus down hunt it
some earrings on it give me a four
finger ring
150 give me some shoes give me a couple
of suits
hit my boys off with a couple stacks you
know and then i got a call from the uh
president of the bank on the army base
the next day he's like you're 50 000 in
the hope
i was like nah you're wrong because in
my mind
i thought i had a million but so when we
went and looked at the paperwork
i was 50 000 whole because i was just
writing checks like crazy
and my parents have always raise me
using scare tactics because uh
75 of all professional athletes when
they're done five years after they're
done have nothing and they didn't want
me to be like that so
i had to hire a business manager i think
it was a great lesson
i have six children and i want them to
respect more
than just having their daddy in shack
like when i come into the parent two
teacher meetings and they call me dr
o'neill
gets me hard not this hard that's hard
just
of course your daddy's shack and he did
a lot but the father also has a
doctorate
father also owns businesses your father
is also very respectful he's very
charitable
i want them to see me as is more than
just a uh retired great basketball
player
[Music]
this one's a little bit
all here which one this one chiba gold
[Music]
i don't want a little fighter
still not making a face though nope
still holding straight
so the mythology around you is so
enormous that the only way to get to the
truth
is to fact check the legend himself so
here i'll hit you with some larger than
life shack
focus go ahead and you just tell me if
it's truth or fiction okay
is it true that you once saved carlos
mencia's life when he was getting
savagely heckled by dr dre and snoop
dogg
at a comedy show yeah
[Music]
yeah he did a joke that was out in the
borderline
and they was getting ready to check him
so i just you know
helped him get out the back door fact or
fiction used to have police lights on
your truck
and you once pulled over darius
[Music]
i don't remember that because if i
wasn't working that day i would get in
trouble
so let me just go that one's fiction
that one's fixed i'm just going to
record
say i refuse to answer any questions on
the grounds that it may incriminate me
is it i refuse to ask any questions
is it true that you have the record for
the largest singular purchase in walmart
history
that's true i got traded from miami to
phoenix and
i had an apartment that i got in one day
was three bedroom nice apartment
when i shop i don't shop i already know
what i want when i go there and i just
go get it so if i got to get tiles i'm
just going
30 tiles 30 low tiles i need pots and
pans grab it
what got me was the tvs because i
ordered about six tvs
that's what got me i'll catch up with
you 70 grand
67 thousand did you give paul pierce's
nickname the truth
yes because i don't look at the sky
report because it don't matter because
every time i go play against a player he
reminds me of this barbecue chicken
my fam that's what i'm doing any player
that's going
to call uncle aqua how are
first one going so the other ones i just
took her back was this one
no face no face he played
when he was doing work that game i was
like you know what this kid is the truth
is it true that you gave nsync their
first big break by having them record in
your home
studio after you saw him perform the
national anthem at an orlando magic
it was one of my worst music career
mistakes ever
i could have signed them and backstreet
boys i think i let them
record my studio for a dollar but i just
didn't understand that music and
my biggest mistakes not investing in
starbucks
not signing nsync and backstreet boys
we're on five shacks on six working
ahead
but we have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that graham where we
do a deep dive on our guest instagram
pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll bust out the laptop i'll
show you the picture you just tell me
the bigger story does that sound good
you want me to work well you can chill
on that if you want to oh you want me to
wait i'm moving too fast for you a
little hot
i'm trying to keep up i'm on my heels
over here i still haven't made a face
america
all right jack first things first
america should i drink some water or not
it activates it let me take a little nah
i ain't gonna take myself
what's going on here looks like you're
hoisting gronk
yeah gronk is the strongest white dude
i've ever felt
not felt let me take it back
[Laughter]
is the strongest white guy i've ever
picked up he's very strong he likes to
party i like to party
and this was my first shaq's front house
in miami it was cool
until he started doing pelvic thrusts
behind my head
like if you hold somebody up and they
don't move it's cool but once they start
doing the you know the pelvic thrusts i
had to put them down yeah yao ming is
the same size as my favorite convenience
store
7-eleven yes he's really 7-11 he likes
to say he's 7-6
[ __ ] can i say [ __ ] on the show
absolutely
let him fly he's way up there oh my god
he's and he just
dwarfs me so every time i see him i got
to take a picture is this in
shanghai every time i go to china i uh
reach out to him
because funny story i kind of got in
trouble for this but right
i wasn't like they they uh they used the
word racist but
that was far from that so when i was
growing up all the chinese movies were
like this
you want me to eat your hot wing they
were like that right yeah so i was just
trying to
i'm just trying to you know have some
fun y'all me
you dare come to the u.s and you want to
battle check so i was doing stuff like
that so my father got really upset
and he said you shouldn't do that and i
said why i'm just he said because
of when yao ming was young he used to
write me letters
well he's like man this kid's been
idolizing you i didn't want to tell you
but he's been idolized you've been
writing letters show them a little bit
more i was just
you know i'm just trying to you know i'm
shack full and you come from over
so but people you know they they
actually you know took it the wrong way
but my father was very upset he said you
need to show this young man so when i
got home he used to send me christmas
cards
yeah you guys have really really cool
relationships yeah yeah so every time i
go to china i just try to you know reach
out to him
do you remember giving me a smooch that
was you
on the top of the head i didn't
recognize you it was you
this is at the super bowl a few years
ago you bastard you tried to switch it
up with the beer
trying to come in here and tell me your
name was america he told me he was
justin timberlake
he sent the email and said justin
timberlake want to interview
i have a confession yes these wings are
not cold they're hot
i'm sweating and my boys are sweating
that's how hot they are
i'll let you figure out what my boys are
[Music]
which one was that adobo loco kahlo hey
kid out of hawaii
i almost made a face
[Music]
god darned this is the one that i'm
scared of
the next one pan in get the scarf
[Music]
so as we touched on in your intro inside
the nba it's won nine emmy awards and
i'm sure i'm not alone
and thinking that it's the best sports
show on tv how has your attitude towards
the sports press
shifted since becoming an analyst like
are you more sympathetic to the sports
media now than you were during your
playing days
no i realized that everyone has a job to
do
being in the game for a long time i
could tell who's being personal and
who's not
i have the ability to when i hear
criticism i turn off being shaq
for a while and then my intelligence
kicks in like she's actually a great
player but
so then i'm just focused on the back i
am a great player but
they're right i'm only shooting 45 for
the free-throw line so
there's some validity here when he said
that and then i turn the shack back on i
won't be upset
i want to do a thought exercise i want
you to think about if twitter and
instagram
existed when you were in the nba would
that be good for shaq
would that be bad for sure it'll be both
i always say what's on my mind
and sometimes you have to be politically
correct sometimes i am sometimes i'm not
but as far as advertising the market i
definitely would have been a
trillionaire by now but also would have
gotten to some trouble
you know i always tell people especially
when i'm doing speeches yeah i'm shack
i'm nice but don't put anybody on the
pedestal
jack you ready to move on i'm waiting on
you timberlake
which one is this the garlic reaper
sauce it's the garlic reaper
[Music]
my boys are sweating real bad oh
you tricked me oh my
[Music]
i'm not gonna make a face though
so since retiring from the nba you've
launched the second career in law
enforcement
working as a reserved officer in several
cities and then even last year becoming
an honorary deputy in clayton county
georgia i'm a real deputy what advice do
you have for talking your way out of a
speeding ticket
i'm still not making a face though
i don't talk my way out of speeding
tickets because
police officers have a heart and people
have it hard
if he pulled me over i probably did it
and this comes from
being raised by a drill sergeant you
show every man respect and
show every woman respect so when i get
pulled over
yes sir no sir i have a i have a badge
but i don't
flash it um and i ask them that do
something wrong you with speed
my bad i apologize they give me a ticket
take it have a great day be safe that's
what it's all about ain't about
i'm this and that got time for that
because most people have jobs to do also
right most people are under a lot of
stress
i ain't trying to get blown away and
then you've made some noise about
possibly running for sheriff in 2020.
i'm gonna do it in 2024.
2024. i think i spoke too early
cause i got a lot going on right now and
when i become sheriff
i want to be there for the people like
right now i'm djing doing it like okay
like i don't want to be i don't want to
be that guy
i thought i thought this was hot this is
nothing
however i over exaggerated
the bomb beyond insanity hot sauce
[Music]
where you be getting all this stuff from
that's from kansas
kansas don't know how to do no hot wings
kansas
oh i apologize kansas
it's time to reach for that jug you lied
to me
oh oh oh guess what got me
god
all right shaq oh you're a [ __ ] liar
shack
but with the proliferation of the
internet and camera phones there's so
much more than what's just on the nba
business or espn so what we're going
to do is show you some of the great
internet best of the worst basketball
clips
and i just want you to react to what
you're seeing
how you doing shaq all right
all right shaq does this take you back
i'm not washing it around does this take
you back to your high school phase
that's exactly what happened all right
next preparing for a potential rebound
[Music]
[Applause]
second breather oh my goodness
got some ice cube chapstick my lips are
do we have ice cube
chapstick good do we have a napkin
oh give me some isis huh
going in with the ice
and then one more for you is this an out
of line move by this guy
[Music]
i'm moving nuts
[Music]
so let me yes hello don't be
no no i think if you can handle this you
can handle any hot sauce in the world
shag i've got a pan
on that crack that's how hot it is look
at that
you pan it in see the tears coming up
one time i ate something hot i'm lactose
intolerant so i dropped some milk
i went to the bathroom the chemistry
there you have a bubble or force
no i can't say yeah so you usually when
you're booboo you
have two feet now yeah yeah it was
coming out so hot i had the wrinkles
[Music]
all right last one last two last two
we're almost there shaq
this is hellfire fear this
dip it in some milk okay go for it
go for it give that a wash
i don't know if that's gonna make things
better or worse but we'll find out now
oh my god oh my god
all right jack we've touched on many
aspects of your multi-pronged career
but you can go down so many rabbits with
all that you've touched
outside the court and inside the court
as one of the most pedigreed practical
jokers what's the best prank you've ever
pulled on charles barkley welcome to
shaq's edition of snotty nose wings i
feel like snotty pippin up here evening
i can't tell you but charles doesn't
like to wear underwear so
one time we put some extra lotion and
vaseline
inside the slacks when they pulled it up
it felt wet down there one of the most
underrated shows of all time is shaq
versus where you take on other athletes
in their own sports
were you more proud of your performance
boxing oscar de la hoya or swimming
against michael phelps
big swimming is michael phelps i sit
home while i watch tv
and i'll say that could be like
you i can interview people like that's
that that's just
that's just a guy in me i can do that i
can do it like every
guy does it right so i was like okay you
give me an advantage i think i could
beat most of these great athletes and
crazy the only guy i beat was charles
barkley in golf
yeah you remember that clip mm-hmm here
it is right here
i'm not gonna leave that one i don't
trust you
[Music]
all right check this is the last step
yeah how far is this camera pan out
give a shackle wide can you see that
see that little two napkins if you make
that then i'll eat it
we're putting a wager on this one i'll
eat it regardless
no you gotta make it i'll eat it
regardless so i'll put a little extra on
the last wing
wow schoenberger where's my where's that
ball right here no we don't do this
okay okay wait
it's too close
you see this camera guy all right
ready yeah i'm ready go
get another shot
[Music]
yes i don't have to either all right
shaq you don't have to eat thank you
i'll eat
[Music]
doctor let the fans down well that meal
a bit of a bet
it's on you oh that's not me oh
but you know what jack we still have
one more hurdle to dunk on before we get
you out of here
and you know you've won an mvp you've
won four nba championships
even a gold medal now i'm not the
world's best free thrower but you also
have that record
for the most attempted free throws with
none made in a game
so this is that's not true eleven what's
your name i went gerald for eleven yeah
one in december uh december eighth two
thousand oh the family i won a
championship
it's true that's true but what we're
gonna do is
go against each other in a free throw
shoot off now it's not just me
it's gonna be best of five wait sit down
yes sir you have to eat
you have to eat a shack sauce wing you
never heard of the shack sauce
no it's a full education right now says
all these sauces combined
you can help me all right
whoever loses you
why do i have to because what's going to
give me to eat this because it's the
shack so i want to see
it without making a face
it's called the shack sauce all the
sauces combined
this is disgusting that's beautiful
all right wait wait
hippy dippy green and then a little
classic to boot
now here's the situation we're having a
free throw off no
you have to eat that because then i'll
have the free throw
no negotiations here all right but let's
put something
let's put something at stake for the
free throw off
okay let's do it if you beat me i'll put
5000 towards your favorite journey
irc rc all right deal
without making a face you got to eat the
whole thing buddy well i don't know if i
can this isn't really disgusting no it's
not it's great it's called the shack
sauce
you got it go go go everybody come on go
not making a face
all right that's good all right this is
hot
yes it's very [ __ ] hot
[Music]
all right best of five i'm a very
gracious host do you want to go first or
you want me to go first
sister girl at best of five i'll go for
right here
from behind the chair okay five shots
come behind the chair
[Music]
ready ready
one you sit behind the chair
two for two
you need to clarify your rules you're
gonna you're gonna run
the black stuff curry
eyes closed on this one all right
i made it all right you missed him okay
so there's still a chance
four out of five from shaq
big money on the line behind the chair
[Music]
lot at stake one
thank you shaq very generous of you
[Music]
step two for three two for three until
we can tie
three for four oh last one
bouncing back pressure on the line
[Music]
that's what you said all right well here
we are at the end of the line
shaq what a run it's been and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my man
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
this is shaq tickets on sale now shaq's
fun house miami
don't want to miss it you already had
two and they were outstanding you don't
want to
oh no milk for you you don't want to
miss this one
we will have shaq sauce wings there
thank you man thank you
have you ever seen the show hot ones
where they eat the hot wings
you ever seen that show when i eat the
hot wings
i don't think so that's what i'm doing
these [ __ ] hot little
[ __ ]
this one this one the shack sauce this
one is the hottest one
yourself i know i already got to take a
[ __ ]
and this other one what's the other one
the [ __ ] ghost ripper peeper [ __ ]
this one this one
those will creep up on you i know i got
a [ __ ] already then i had been drinking
milk i'm about to go take a [ __ ] right
now
right in the studio all right we're done
all right love you guys
i'll call oh when i get in the car baby
love you
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much what's up spice lords
camera guy bill here
i just couldn't get enough of this glitz
and glamour so i came back to tell you
if you want to buy some official hot
ones merchandise go to
shop.firstfreefeast.com
if you're lazy you can just uh click one
of these uh t-shirts down there
this is camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill